in the early morning hours over gondwana
the air is calm and still
as the stars gradually fade away in the
rapidly lightening sky
a few clouds high in the atmosphere
catch a glimpse of the sunrise to come
[Music]
reflecting the same pink that now grows
through the sky's lower reaches
[Music]
suddenly and silently without a warning
or fanfare a flaring brightness pierces
the horizon
and the orb of the sun emerges
shimmering appearing improbably large
reflected in the ocean's surface
[Music]
the world turns and as the sun's light
washes over the eastern shore of
gondwana the landscape of this devonian
world is transformed
land surfaces that were dimly lit by
diffuse and hazy pre-dawn glow mere
moments ago are now cast into sharp and
eerie contrast as the sun's impossibly
low angle projects elongated shadows
from every hillside bluff and living
thing
under this bizarre lighting the reality
of a 400 million year old terrestrial
world
is revealed
gone are the days of the baron lifeless
supercontinent
this immense land surface is now covered
from shore to shore with terrestrial
life
but it is still early days for the
organisms who have forsaken the safety
of the ocean
[Music]
insects and worms inch crawl and clamber
but none have yet taken to the skies
plants alien and strange to our eyes
only recognizable as such by their green
coloration spread haphazardly over the
reddish soil
there are few of the leaves stalks seeds
and roots that will come to characterize
later vascular plants and trees
instead these early colonizers creep and
extend occasionally projecting a fragile
rubbery stem a few tens of centimeters
above the earth
even under the low morning sun the
shadows of these plants are like the
primitive plants themselves
stunted
but occasionally
huge
slender shadows extend many meters
across the rolling landscape
[Music]
immense organic but otherwise
featureless towers
the largest of which reaches eight
meters in height and one meter across
[Music]
in an early terrestrial world dominated
by primitive plants no more than a metre
high
these monumental columns are huge
and bizarre
[Music]
but they
are not plants
neither have they been wrought by the
might of the earth or the craft of any
sentient life as we know it
they
are fungi
unimaginably huge mushroom skyscrapers
that dwarf all other life on the surface
of the devonian earth
[Music]
it is strange enough to consider a
fungus reaching such mammoth proportions
today
but it is even more remarkable in the
relatively young terrestrial niche
[Music]
the first fossils of these mysterious
organic structures
recovered from gaspe bay in quebec
were described more than 160 years ago
by canadian geologist john william
dawson
as was not uncommon at the time john
dawson was a creationist
believing that all living things
bestowed upon the earth were of the
great creators making
arguing vehemently against charles
darwin's new and radical theory of
evolution
it is perhaps not surprising then when
faced with these bizarre devonian
fossils dawson's explanation erred on
the side of the familiar
they were he claimed the remains of
partially rotten giant conifers
and he named them
prototaxities roughly translating as
first u
[Music]
but dawson supposedly rotten specimens
weren't even the first prototaxity's
fossils to be collected
[Music]
some 17 years earlier one of darwin's
friends and colleagues joseph hooker
recovered similar remnants from devonian
rocks in scotland
unfortunately the samples being mislaid
until 2012.
[Music]
in the intervening years many other
examples of prototaxities were found
from terrestrial rocks all over the
world
now they can be found in abundance in
deposits from the mid or division 417
million years old to the late devonian
aged 360 million years
these mysterious living monuments
existed for 20 times the length of
humanity's own reign
given the immense diversity of fungi
today
from slime molds fungal infections to
edible oyster mushrooms
the bizarre morphology of prototaxities
has attracted many alternative
explanations
from that of a stringy alga like seaweed
to a fortuitously rolled up bundle of
non-vascular plants like liverwort
but the scientific consensus of the 21st
century is that these seemingly
impossible structures are in fact
members of a long overlooked but
nevertheless omnipresent kingdom
the fungi
prototaxity's large size and widespread
habitat throughout the devonian is a
clear implication that they were
successful
and likely owed that success to a long
and prosperous evolutionary line
the humble fungi which live their lives
practically out of sight and without
which many of our modern ecosystems
would not be able to survive
have been lurking in the background for
longer than we may imagine
so as we rewind the evolutionary clock
from this curious age when vast
mushrooms towered over all life on earth
how far must we go to find their
beginnings
what were the first fungi on the planet
and how did they come to shape our
modern world
the answer might just be more amazing
than we could have possibly imagined
the implications stretching far into our
future
as well
as our past
[Music]
the history of our world spans more than
four billion years
that's a lot of ground to cover
this episode of history of the earth is
brought to you by our partners at
curiositystream
where you can find a vast catalogue of
documentaries to help you get to grips
with this immense span of time
[Music]
300 million years and ancient earth are
two that we enjoy recently
but there are thousands of others to
choose from on practically any topic you
can think of
so head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash
history of the earth to sign up
use our code history of the earth and
save 25
right now that's an entire year for
14.99
just 1.25 a month
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
in the blue mountains of eastern oregon
bright alpine lakes shine like gemstones
amidst the mountain meadows
[Music]
marching pine forests stretch off into
the distance
[Music]
the mallard national forest is a
peaceful natural wilderness
popular with hunters herders and hikers
alike
and yet unlikely as it seems this forest
is home to the largest and one of the
oldest living beings
on earth
[Music]
like the mythical sasquatch it hides
from sight
this enigmatic organism can only be
spotted at certain times of the year and
then only if you know where to look
however unlike bigfoot once glimpsed
this elusive entity is unable to make
good its escape
since it is rooted quite literally
beneath the ground
in 1998 a team of scientists set out to
map the distribution of a deadly
pathogenic fungus in eastern oregon
in the moist autumns of the u.s pacific
coast dark honey mushrooms sprout all
around the bases of ailing pine trees
named for the golden colour of their
caps that they are certainly attractive
specimens
but they're a symptom of a much more
sinister phenomenon unfolding beneath
the surface
for the honey mushrooms are only the
fruiting bodies of the armillorea fungus
which survives by infecting and
attacking the roots and trunks of living
trees
it is a parasite feared by foresters all
over the world
and by the time its mushrooms emerge it
is typically too late for the luckless
tree
which has been eaten away from the
inside by the insinuating fungal fibers
in order to investigate the spread of
this fungal parasite throughout the
idyllic woodland of malur
the scientists combined traditional
mycological techniques
with the latest in 20th century genetic
fingerprinting
taking samples of the fungal fibers from
separate afflicted trees they combined
them in a petri dish to see if they
would grow together and fuse implying
that they were of compatible genetic
stock
and by extracting and analyzing their
dna
the similarities and differences in
their genes could be compared side by
side
the results of this analysis
were astounding
at every tree they sampled over a 10
square kilometer area
the armeloria fungus was genetically
identical
just as the cells in our own bodies are
genetic clones of one another
so too with these fungal fibers
and just as our genetic makeup defines
our individuality from other members of
our species
so the fibers of armellorea were all
part of one immense fungal individual
here just beneath the forest floor
was the largest individual organism
on earth
nicknamed the humongous fungus for good
reason
three meters beneath the surface it
extends over an area of some 2384
acres
[Music]
it dwarfs the largest living animal the
33 meter long blue whale
and even trumps the largest plant colony
the 107 acre quaking aspen of utah named
pando
and yet this monstrous fungus
could easily be missed
if not for its golden mushrooms and the
dying trees it leaves in its wake
[Music]
because the immense body of armor luria
is actually made of a network of
gossamer fibers
which even at their densest look little
more than white moldy fur
and yet this mycelial network the true
vegetative form of many fungi all over
the world is much greater than the sum
of its diminutive parts
not as an individual per se
but a collective
the armillaria of eastern oregon is not
only remarkable in its size
but also its age
based on its rate of growth scientists
estimate this humongous fungus to be at
least 2
400 years old
and possibly almost twice that
it has seen the rise and fall of
civilizations and religions
the lives and deaths of almost 100 human
generations
but this ancient organism is far from
dormant
it like all mycelia is vibrantly alive
continually shifting and migrating
through the forest soil
much faster and stranger than the roots
of a plant
for as we now know from roots discovered
in 2017
mycelium itself
seems to have been around for far longer
perhaps
for more than two billion years
roughly half
of earth's history
[Music]
the mycelial network stretching beneath
the forest floor is composed of
countless fungal fibers known as hyphae
each five times thinner than a human
hair
but with the capacity to branch and fuse
to create a woven mesh
this three-dimensional net can be so
dense for the single teaspoon of
mycelium can contain as much as 10
kilometers of ultrafine hyphae
each fungal individual defines and
expands its borders through the probing
growth of hyphal tips
similar to the exploratory hairs of
plants roots and shoots
yet far more numerous
a large mycelial network may contain
billions of hyphal tips whose
exploration through the soil helps to
locate food sources grow and renew the
fungal body
hyphae may be small
but they are mighty
despite being only one cell thick
they can nevertheless knit together to
create solid three-dimensional
structures
[Music]
like the golden edible mushroom caps of
armillaria
[Music]
the rigid shells of the polypore bracket
fungus
and even the towering columns of
prototaxities
there have been documented cases of
newly surfaced roads being ripped open
by the growth of mushrooms through the
tarmac
and experiments have shown that growing
hyphy can summon enough force to
penetrate kevlar
of course the main purpose of these
mycelial hyphae is not to pierce armor
and ravage our infrastructure
when they're not assembling elaborate
fruiting bodies haify are primarily
occupied with the all-consuming task of
feeding the voracious fungal entity
oozing digestive enzymes out into the
space around them they supervise the
breakdown of organic matter
[Music]
then reabsorb the products
but they are capable of much more than
just devouring
the probing behavior of millions of
hyphal tips is like that of an immense
swarm
acquiring and integrating information
simultaneously on a massively parallel
basis
and on a scale that rivals most home
computers
[Music]
recent experiments having proven that
mycelium can navigate its way through
mazes to find the quickest route to the
end
[Music]
deciding whether to pursue or abandon a
path of exploration relies on
communication between distant reaches of
the mycelial network
although scientists are still unsure
precisely how such communication takes
place
they have observed it to be lightning
fast
much faster for example than the
chemical discourse of plants
and perhaps more similar to the
electrical signaling along our own nerve
cells
the hyphy grow sever or reinforce their
links dynamically based on the
information they receive the mycelial
network on the whole
may be likened
to a brain
are my serial fungi therefore capable of
decision making
problem solving
like octopi lacking a conventional
nervous system yet seeming to think with
their tentacles
do they possess a spark of intelligence
in that hyphal brain a composition of
many life forms coming together to
create a larger more formidable whole
acquiring new abilities horizontally
if so it is unlike any intelligence that
we are accustomed to recognizing
and yet it was charles darwin who wrote
that intelligence is based on how
efficient a species becomes at doing the
things they need to survive
[Music]
given the monumental success of the
giant armillaria and all other fungi
whose bodies are composed of shifting
entwining haiful nets
it's not hard to appreciate their
efficiency
even if acknowledging intelligence is a
step too far
though bizarrely they do seem to exhibit
traits of memory on occasion
without the need for a brain as we would
recognize it
in truth we still know very little of
fungi and their strange collective lives
by themselves mycelial networks are
forced to be reckoned with
and yet their power to shape and
transform a living ecosystem is even
more formidable
the inexorable growth of hyphae and the
enzyme cocktail they excrete is enough
to shatter rock over and over
creating the first soils in a bare
landscape
and then through their dense organic net
holding the ground in place
it is fungi who help pave the way for
modern plants and animals to colonize
virgin ground
[Music]
and it was likely fungi who helped
plants to make the leap onto land in the
first place
417 million years ago
[Music]
for those first colonizing plants did
not yet have the root systems that would
allow them to access nutrients from the
thin or division soil
[Music]
and so researchers think that mycelial
networks stepped up and fulfilled that
role
at least for a few tens of millions of
years
a role they continue to be an integral
part of in forests all over the world
in this way it was fungi who have
enabled shaped and guided the course of
terrestrial evolution
[Music]
fungi make mushrooms but first they have
to unmake
something else
in this great recycling of organic
matter that keeps our world moving
keeps evolution ever pushing onwards
they are the main players
and yet
still now despite decades of research we
still know so little about these
creatures with whom we share a common
ancestor
modern science is still delving deep to
find out just how far these inscrutable
fungal lives are entwined with our own
and with every other living thing
on earth
[Music]
in the year 1487
so says the spanish friar diego duran
writing two generations later
a particularly significant occasion took
place at the mexica aztec capital of
tenochtitlan one of the largest cities
the world had ever seen
the beating heart of the most powerful
of all mesoamerican empires
an early anthropologist of sorts duran
sought to preserve the history of the
rapidly disappearing aztecs
by his day subject to christianity and
harsh spanish colonial rule
he did this by doing what many refused
to do by talking and engaging with the
surviving elders recording for posterity
what they told
on this particular occasion in 1487
juran records a particularly grisly
event
[Music]
the new emperor ahwed sotol one of the
most formidable military leaders in the
entire history of the new world
did things on a grand scale
following his accession and successful
conquests into new lands over the course
of four days tens of thousands of
captive warriors ascended the temple
mayor at the heart of the city
one by one their beating hearts were cut
from their chests
sacrificial blood offered to the gods as
part of the ceremonial rededication of
the empire
yet for those not taking part in the
orgy of human sacrifice
the extended coronation festival is
cause for uninhibited celebration
chocolate is drunk songs are sung and a
very special delicacy is enjoyed
known locally as tejna cattle the flesh
of the gods is a small spindly mushroom
with a white stem
and golden cap
celebrants eat it raw all with a little
honey
and are instantly transformed
some find themselves laughing and
dancing uncontrollably
others experience strange and disturbing
visions of war
demons
or even their own deaths
some are overcome weeping openly
while others take quietly to their
houses in a meditative mood
and after these journeys and visions
they come together to discuss what they
saw
they believe that the mushrooms were
gifted to the aztec people by the
serpent god
quetzalcoatl and that consuming them
gives them the power to commune with
their gods
they are a frequent component of
celebrations healing and religious
rituals whether juran or subsequent
spanish colonizers also sample the
sacred mushrooms we do not know
and later conquistadors made great
efforts to erase all records of the
mind-altering substances as well as the
culture of the pre-columbian americas
after the fall of the aztec empire it
was difficult to learn more about these
supposedly psychedelic fungi
or even identify the individual
mushrooms responsible
their very existence became
controversial
was the flesh of the gods little more
than a myth itself invented by a
traumatized chronicle at a distance from
the horrors of human sacrifice
samples sent to harvard arrived to
rotten to be properly studied and it was
only when 20th century adventurers
retraced diego duran's steps to mexico
and witnessed a modern-day mushroom
ceremony
that the psychoactive mushrooms were
finally found to be real after all
now of course we know these
transcendental fungi as magic mushrooms
containing a chemical compound called
psilocybin that can produce a
psychedelic trip and hallucinations like
that of the drug lsd
[Music]
in fact lsd itself was first synthesized
from the chemicals produced by different
kind of fungus
and there are many such mushrooms
capable of inducing similar experiences
while diego duran might have been one of
the first westerners to hear of the
ritual consumption of these mushrooms
the 15th century aztecs were by no means
the first to partake
ancient manuscripts that predate the
spanish conquest depict feathered
deities holding and eating mushrooms
and mushroom-shaped statues have been
discovered from mesoamerica stretching
back to the second millennium bc
[Music]
elsewhere in the world reverence for the
spiritual mushroom extends back even
further
cave paintings in algeria created
between 7000 and 9000 bce depict a godly
figure with an animal's head and
mushroom-like figures sprouting from its
shoulders and arms
in classical greece a secretive
ceremonial meeting known as the
elusinian mysteries frequented by the
likes of plato has long been theorized
to involve the use of the psychedelic
ergot fungi
it is the kind of bizarre image that the
straight-minded might find hard to
interpret
but which makes ultimate sense to a
psilocybin connoisseur
the deep interlinked history of humans
and psychedelic fungi has even given
rise to a controversial theory
that it is the mushrooms themselves that
are the architects of our humanity
anthropologists have long grappled with
the puzzling speed by which human
culture social structure commerce and
art seem to appear among the human
species 50 to 70 000 years ago during
the paleolithic era
scars on fossilized leaves from 48
million years ago indicative of
infection by the cordyceps fungus
suggests fungi may have been
manipulating mines for as long as there
have been minds to manipulate
witnessing the transformative effects of
psilocybin on the human mind today
and the uncanny ability of certain fungi
to influence the life forms around them
certain fringe scholars have suggested
it was the hallucinogenic effects of
these mushrooms that allowed our
ancestors to expand their minds
in the first place
[Music]
this so-called stoned ape theory of
human evolution certainly sits at the
fringes of science
and with little tangible evidence from
that time
unfortunately we may simply never know
how much of our modern civilization we
owe to the psychedelic trips of our
forebears
[Music]
but even if hallucigenic mushrooms have
played a marginal role
fungi in general have had a potent
connection with humans for at least as
long as there have been humans
certain yeasts in particular that live
on our bodies have adapted so much that
they can't live without us
[Music]
neanderthal remains have been found with
traces of penicillin producing molds
ground into their teeth
thought to be a treatment for dental
problems
in a practice similar to that known from
indigenous australians and ancient
egyptians
more recently otzi the iceman the five
thousand year old mummy found frozen in
the ice of the austro-italian alps
carried with him pieces of the polypore
fungus
which he likely used as tinder for
starting a fire
ink caps were used by medieval
chroniclers to record words on
parchments
and untold amounts of edible mushrooms
have been invaluable allies throughout
history
despite being feared and shunned in many
cultures
[Music]
eventually penicillin would be
rediscovered accidentally and isolated
into a powerful antimicrobial medicine
just in time to turn the tide of the
second world war
we are at least part of our success as a
species to the humble fungus
and humans are far from the only
organisms that benefit from the diverse
capabilities of the fungal kingdom
as has become better understood for the
last decade or so the mycelial networks
that spread ubiquitously through forest
floors all over the world do more than
merely feed themselves
they also act as a vital communication
network for the plants in the forest
it has been likened to a social network
for the woodland penetrating the roots
of trees and weaving them together and
providing vital nutrients that support
their growth
some scholars have gone so far as to
liken this activity to trees talking to
one another via underground fungal webs
[Music]
much more akin to cooperation rather
than competition
for this wood wide web is capable of so
much more
it can transmit warnings between
individual trees
[Music]
if one comes under insect attack the
fungal network beneath the ground
carries the warning to nearby vegetation
allowing them to mount a chemical
defense before the threat arrives
and in a strange altruistic tendency
carbon is moved from areas of abundance
to those of scarcity
this is biological cooperation or
symbiosis on the scale of entire
ecosystems
[Music]
but fungi are also capable of
collaborating on a much more individual
and intimate level
lycan are strange plant-like growth that
can be found on rocky surfaces man-made
monuments and even certain slow-moving
animals
the crusted scaly or feathered life
forms are thought to encrust as much as
eight percent of the earth's surface
often in places where no other living
thing can survive
they can even withstand the freezing
desiccated and irradiated environment of
space
[Music]
but lichens are not actually a single
organism
rather they are an intimate symbiosis
between photosynthesizing algae and
fungus
many different species of algae and
fungi can come together and lyconise
the specific individuals determining
their lycon's ultimate appearance and
capabilities
their relationship was actually one of
the first symbioses to be described in
the natural world
a swiss botanist simon schwendener put
forward his dual hypothesis of lichens
in 1869.
in this he posited that the fungi were
enslaving parasites that had forced the
photosynthetic algae into service to
produce sugar and energy for them
albeit with the promise of harbour and
nutrients in return
[Music]
today however we know the relationship
between the two lycan partners to be
much more equitable
although the deeper scientists probe the
more complex the picture becomes
[Music]
in most lichens there are more than two
cooperating organisms
[Music]
as several different fungal species work
together in a way that mutually benefits
all parties
[Music]
indeed lycan scholars have yet to find
how deep the symbiotic rabbit hole goes
[Music]
whether with algae and lichens with
trees in the wood wide web or with
humanity in modern civilizations
fungi have made themselves invaluable
partners in many of earth's ecosystems
their integration and interaction with
nearly every living thing on the planet
ultimately blurs the line of where funky
end and everything else begins
[Music]
a collection of organisms not just
master and slave
not just individual singers
but a song
[Music]
and so
tracing the origins of these remarkable
organisms requires that we first
understand
exactly
what they are
[Music]
chernobyl
1986
a catastrophic explosion at a nuclear
plant in what is now northern ukraine
sees radioactive waste spread across
much of europe
for many kilometers around the leaking
plant contamination levels are high
enough to cause radiation poisoning and
deadly cancers
in arguably the worst nuclear disaster
the world has ever seen a 10 square
kilometer area of the surrounding forest
is killed outright by radioactive
material amounting to 20 times that of
the atomic bombings of hiroshima and
nagasaki
[Music]
the region becomes known as the red
forest
after the colour of its dead and dying
trees
every animal that couldn't flee
ultimately perishing from the
overwhelming corruption
after the disaster the chernobyl plant
itself was closed down
but the radioactive fuel it still
contained was left in situ
in order to prevent any further reaction
and to protect the immediate area from
the effects of radiation
the fuel is stored in huge vats of water
the clear water itself
glows with unearthly blue cherenkov
radiation
generated as the decaying fuel splits
water molecules releasing energy in the
form of light
only the water
isn't clear anymore
over the years it has become
blackened
and the agent of this darkening is
remarkably
a fungus
many species of fungi are known to be
extremophiles
they are able to tolerate conditions
well beyond the limits of what we would
consider a comfortable existence
one such tolerance is the ability to
withstand high levels of radioactivity
the same levels that were enough to
ravage the planets and animals of the
red forest
and so here in the intensely radioactive
waters of the abandoned chernobyl plant
the radio-resistant fungi have found a
way to survive
even more surprisingly these hardy
organisms seem to be doing more than
merely surviving here
scientists have found them growing
towards the hot radioactive particles
and using the energy from radioactive
decay in much the same way as plants use
the light energy from the sun
against unimaginable dangers
these fungal organisms
have found a way to feed on
radioactivity
perhaps digging deep in their primordial
genetic makeup to find a new niche in
the wake of radioactive devastation
the discovery has staggering
implications
if a mushroom can adapt to eat nuclear
waste then surely other waste products
can be consumed too
perhaps most importantly
plastics
[Music]
the remarkable colonisers of chernobyl
comprise just a single variety among a
staggering diversity of fungal species
with seemingly endless adaptations to a
wide range of habitats lifestyles and
symbiotic association
there are single-celled yeasts vast
mycorrhizal networks
funky that build mushrooms of every
conceivable shape and size
funky that are cultured exclusively
inside the nests of leafcutter ants
fungi that live only on and in the human
body
and not to mention the countless
lycanized forms hiding in plain sight
although only 150 000 species have been
formally described
scientists estimate there may be as many
as 3.8 million species here on earth
outnumbering plants by roughly 10 to one
they have been incredibly successful
and are incredibly old 500 million years
at the very least
if close enough in evolution mycelium
from some fungi can blend seamlessly
with other species
of course given this cross-species
breeding and being
fungi are almost the very definition of
other
the polyphonic way they experience the
world is immensely different to our
monophony
with so much diversity it can become
difficult to identify the features that
unite fungi rather than set them apart
from one another
one mycological idea is that we should
abandon dividing them into species
altogether
due to the inadequate categorizations
given to them for hundreds if not
thousands of years
thought to be merely parasites until
very recently
for influential swedish botanist carl
inaeus they were chaos incarnate
others genuinely thought them caused by
lightning strikes
by the 19th century they were
categorized as plants
and only in the mid-1960s where they
granted an entire kingdom of their own
for in reality fungi are closer to
animals
they are eukaryotes set apart from their
bacterial cousins through the presence
of a nucleus and other membrane-bound
machinery inside their cells
they lack the photosynthetic
chloroplasts that plants possess and
despite being historically grouped among
plants on account of their vegetative
lifestyle
fungi actually share more in common with
animals than with any other kingdom
indeed many fungi contain the same
light-sensitive pigments as can be found
in our own eyes and their compatible
biochemistry is what makes them such
potent allies in the field of human
medicine
together with animals and single-celled
protists the fungi are part of a larger
group known as apisticons but justify
their own kingdom through the possession
of unique features shared by neither
animal or protist
[Music]
they are defined in part by their unique
mode of growth
from probing hyphal tips
and the ability of these high fee to
digest their food outside the fungal
body rather than an internal stomach
typically high fee can be recognized by
their ability to branch often at right
angles and to converge and fuse again
further down the line
[Music]
and fungal cells regardless of their
habitat are all strengthened by a
specific kind of biological polymer
known as chitin
some animals also make use of chitin for
protection
it is especially common in the
ecosystems of arthropods like insects
and crabs
but only in fungi is it ubiquitous
around each and every cell
this toolkit of classifying features
allows paleontologists to trace the
fungal kingdom back through the mists of
time
and to begin to search for the origins
of fungi on earth
it is the uniquely hyphal microstructure
found in fossil specimens of
prototaxites that best supports its
fungal interpretation
but an absence of corroborating
biochemistry makes the conclusion of
giant fungi 470 million years ago a
somewhat tentative one
instead paleontologists consider the
oldest uncontested fungal fossils to be
those preserved in intricate cellular
detail in the 410 million year old
glassy church of riney scotland
here a wide diversity of fungal types
are preserved as if in crystal clear
resin painting a picture of a
terrestrial devonian world in which
fungi have already found and exploited
many of their modern day niches
these specimens are by no means the
first of their kind appearing as they do
already adapted to their chosen
lifestyles
but they do serve an important purpose
in modern paleontological analysis
genetic and physiological analysis of
fungi alive today allow them to be
plotted onto an evolutionary
family tree
with more recently derived species
forming the most distant twigs and more
ancestral forms branching closer to the
root
finding and plotting the fossil
specimens onto this family tree helps to
orient those relationships in time as
well as in evolutionary space
and to calibrate estimates on the rate
of fungal evolution on the basis of
genetic transformation
using these statistical tools modern
paleontologists have estimated that the
origins of the fungal kingdom extend
back long before the age of giant
prototaxities
[Music]
indeed they suggest that we should be
searching for the first fungi back in
the neoproterozoic
between
1750 million years ago
before even plants or animals have made
a definitive appearance
long before the green abundance of the
devonian when the terrestrial earth was
still a wasteland
with no soil to speak of
all nutrients trapped within rocks
it seems at least possible that algae
and fungus made it onto the land
together
like the aftermath of chernobyl and
countless mass extinction events before
early pioneers leading the way for more
life
to follow
[Music]
just outside the thriving city of
mujimai in the heart of the democratic
republic of congo
rolling tropical grasslands are pushed
aside by the inexorable advance of
industry
ever since the discovery of diamonds
here in 1909 the gentle hillsides have
been torn open exposing wounds of bright
red soil and filling the rivers with the
same blood red silt
today though one of the most troubled
regions on the planet the area supplies
some 10
of the world's
diamonds prospecting geologists continue
to search for more in the ancient rocks
beneath the surface
there is no other material like it
in the absence of any great mountains or
sharp rocky escarpments in this part of
the country
prospectors must actively drill down
into the rocks beneath their feet
and one such drill core not far from the
bustle of the drc's second city has
revealed hidden treasures although not
the kind that will bring economic
geologists running
the kanshi b-13 core penetrates the
limestone and shady rocks that are
neoproterozoic in age
and which were likely deposited in a
warm perennial lake
[Music]
here as in so many rocks of this age
paleontologists have found spherical
microfossils
that are thought to belong to primitive
eukaryotic algae
[Music]
but at a depth of more than 100 meters
the extracted core contains
something else
something much more remarkable for the
time
in a layer aged between 810 and 715
million years old an international team
of scientists have identified curious
filamentous fossils preserved in three
dimensions by crystalline limestone
each filament is less than 10 microns
100 of a millimeter across and up to a
millimeter in length
[Music]
but together they pack densely into an
interconnected mesh of branching and
fusing strands
in shape and arrangement alone they are
surprisingly similar to the hyphy of
modern mycelial network
but at an age almost double that of the
oldest confirmed fungi
it will take more than morphology to
make a case for these supposed
neoproterozoic fungi
fortunately these filaments are
preserved in such a way that allows
scientists to search for other
strengthening strands of evidence to
support the fungal conclusion
using a technique called raman
spectroscopy which uses laser light to
reveal the nature of chemical bonds in a
structure they found the filaments to be
composed of organic material that had
undergone the same heating and
compression as the surrounding rock
this implies that they are just as
ancient as the limestone that surrounds
them and not the result of some
secondary infiltration
next the researchers employed a kind of
chemical straining that's typically used
to identify fungi in modern soils
the stain clings to the chitin that
uniquely makes up fungal cell walls and
not to anything else
causing the fungal members of a
community to glow green under specific
microscopic light
and sure enough when the fossil
filaments were treated with the stain
they glowed the characteristic
green
suggesting that chitin was a significant
part of their original organic structure
[Music]
these multiple lines of evidence from
morphology to chemical composition are
necessary to substantiate what is
ultimately a remarkable claim
that recognizable fungal mycelia had
already evolved at least
715 million years ago
[Music]
this mycelium would have lived within
the sediment just under the water or at
the shore of the neoproterozoic lake
feeding on decaying organic matter from
algae and bacteria
it is a lifestyle almost identical to
that of many mycelia today
and these fossils suggest it has an
origin deeper in the past than we might
imagine
but even these are not the oldest fungal
candidates found to date
in the far north of the canadian
northwest territories on the desolate
frosted shores of the arctic ocean
dark-coloured shales have been dated to
around 1 billion years old
some 2 or 300 million years older than
the limestones of the drc
here traditional micropaleontological
methods which involve dissolving away
the solid rock to leave behind the
organic material trapped within has
yielded microfossils with a unique shape
and structure that hints at a fungal
affinity
large spheres between three and eight
hundredths of a millimeter across are
attached to narrow filaments which
branch at right angles to one another
researchers have interpreted these
structures as the reproductive spores
and connective hyphae of fungi
and while the wealth of analytical data
is not as great as the younger african
specimens
chemical analysis of these canadian
examples does seem to suggest the
presence of fungal chitin within the
walls as well
although these conclusions are more
tentative the possible appearance of
already distinct fungal structures at
this earlier point in time does seem to
be honing in on the earliest origins of
the fungal kingdom
elsewhere around the world fossils
reveal some of the earliest possible
hollow zoans
the precursors to true animals
that the fossil evidence of fungi seems
to be consistent with genetic estimates
of their appearance too helps to build a
picture of microbial diversity at the
very beginning of the neoproterozoic
perhaps due in part to the stability and
worldwide strife of the boring billion
this then could be the age where our
ancestors and the fungi went their
separate ways
diverging on very different evolutionary
paths
[Music]
however there is one more fungal fossil
candidate which seems to blow this
neatly converging picture apart
in 2017 paleontologists from sweden and
australia found structures inside the
bubbles of ancient lava flows
that also seemed to show a curiously
fungal habit
the key difference is that these samples
from south africa
are 2.4 billion years old
inside these basaltic bubbles which form
naturally as gases attempt to escape
through sticky liquid magma
the researchers have found filaments the
typical dimensions of fungal hyphae
which branch and fuse in a compellingly
mycelial way
the morphology argument may be strong
but the unique preservation and extreme
antiquity of these specimens renders any
supporting chemical analysis impossible
and at more than a billion years older
than when the fungal genome is thought
to have emerged
the fungal interpretation is perhaps too
extraordinary a claim
yet even if they are not true fungi as
we have come to define them
there is no denying the mycelial habit
perhaps more primitive organisms whether
bacteria or some of the first eukaryotes
experimented with a mesh mesh-like
mycelium
long before the fungal kingdom made it
their own
all of these ancient fungal and mycelial
discoveries have been made within the
last five years highlighting just how
immature the science of fungal
paleontology is
much like mycology in general which
hovers awkwardly somewhere between plant
and animal studies
indeed it is only in the last few
decades that ecologists have come to
realize the staggering diversity and
vital importance of fungi in modern
ecosystems
catching glimpses of them within the
fossil record whether in their
monumental success as devonian
prototaxities their understated
diversity in the rhine shirt or in their
earliest microbial manifestations in the
neoproterozoic
reveals just how influential fungi have
been
through much of life's history
they have played a crucial role in
cycling nutrients and shaping ecosystems
for much longer than we may have
imagined
perhaps creating soil in the first place
and certainly keeping it healthy for
other forms of life
it is very likely that it was fungi that
supported and enabled the success of
other kingdoms of life throughout the
neoproterozoic and beyond
just as it was fungi who facilitated the
colonisation of land some 450 million
years ago
as well as the recolonisation of blasted
landscapes after mass extinction events
[Music]
for as much as a billion years or more
it seems everywhere life seeks to
explore
fungi have been one step ahead
preparing the way
[Music]
and with the development of so-called
mica texture being investigated for
space travel and habitation it is a role
that may just continue
long into the future
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
don't forget to like and subscribe
let us know what you think in the
comments and we'll see you
next time
you